THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
OVER THE PAST 24 HOURS,
SOCIAL MEDIA, A LOT OF YOU, YOU
HAVE BLOWN UP WITH EXPRESSIONS
OF CONSERVATIVE OUTRAGE OVER THE
DEMOCRAT'S TREATMENT OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
>> I THINK HISTORY WILL JUDGE
YOU HARSHLY THAT THAT CONCLUSION
IS INESCAPABLE.
>> MOVE ON, YOU MADE IT CLEAR
THAT YOU HAVE NOT LOOKED AT THE
EVIDENCE, AND WE CAN LOOK      M
EVIDENCE, AND WE CAN LOOK      V
EVIDENCE, AND WE CAN LOOK      E
EVIDENCE, AND WE CAN LOOK      O
EVIDENCE, AND WE CAN LOOK      .
>> YOUR OWN CREDIBILITY IN
QUESTION, AND SEEM TO BE GIVING
SANCTION TO BEHAVIOR, THROUGH
THE LANGUAGE YOU USE IN THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE YOU HELD --
>> YOU LIED.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A SACRED TRUST.
YOU HAVE BETRAYED THAT TRUST.
>> Laura: OF COURSE IT IS ALL
DISGUSTING, IT IS INCREDIBLY
NASTY, AND IT IS PATENTLY
UNFAIR.
BUT WHY WOULD ANYBODY BE
SHOCKED, GIVEN THE SAME
DEMOCRATS, WHAT THEY DID LAST
SEPTEMBER TO ANOTHER TRUMP PICK
WHO ALSO HAD A STELLAR LEGAL
CAREER.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO ASK THE
WHITE HOUSE TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE FBI?
>> THE FBI WOULD GATHER WITNESS
STATEMENTS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DEBATE WITH
YOU HOW THEY DO THEIR BUSINESS.
>> SHE IS NOT PART OF THE
CLINTON'S EFFORTS TO GET
REVENGE.
SHE IS A WOMAN WHO CAME WITH
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE TO TELL
HER TRUTH.
THAT WAS A FINAL STATEMENT.
>> I ONLY HAVE 23 SECONDS.
YOU ARE NOT A SLOPPY DRUNK, SO
YOUR ROOMMATE WAS LYING.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, MS. MS.L
>> Laura: REMEMBER, MS. MS.S
>> Laura: REMEMBER, MS. MS.Y
FORD, DECADES-OLD ALLEGATIONS,
CAME AFTER DEMOCRATS REALLY KNOW
MIKE LEAKE HER LETTER.
SIMILARLY, ON TUESDAY, RIGHT
BEFORE BARR'S TESTIMONY, THE
MUELLER LETTER WAS LEAKED, OF
COURSE, TO "THE WASHINGTON POST"
BUT STAY WITH ME.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS CANNOT WIN ON THE
MERIT ON THE SUBSTANCE, WHAT DID
THEY DO?
THEY WANT TO END THE DEBATE AND
GO RIGHT FOR THE JUGULAR.
>> I STRONGLY BELIEVE
JUDGE KAVANAUGH SHOULD WITHDRAW
FROM CONSIDERATION, AND THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD WITHDRAW THIS
NOMINATION IF KAVANAUGH WON'T DO
IT VOLUNTARILY.
>> I JOIN LEADER SCHUMER IN
CALLING FOR JUDGE KAVANAUGH TO
WITHDRAW HIS NAME FROM
CONSIDERATION.
>> I THINK THE NOMINATION SHOULD
BE WITHDRAWN.
>> Laura: OF COURSE KAVANAUGH
REMAINED DEFIANT AND REFUSED TO
BACK DOWN TO THE DEMOCRATS, AND
NOW HE HAS A LIFETIME TENURE ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
THE DEMOCRATS CRASHED AND BURNED
ON KAVANAUGH.
BUT NOT ONLY DID THEIR STUNT
FLOP, THEIR STUNT ACTORS WERE
ACTUALLY FRAUDS AND CRIMINALS.
>> A LOT OF THIS WOULD BE
SUBSTANTIATED IF THERE WAS AN
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS WHAT WE
WANT.
WE ARE NOT LAYING OUT ALL OF THE
FACTS AND ALL OF THE EVIDENCE
RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS NOT OUR OBLIGATION.
>> COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN CHUCK
GRASSLEY TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR INVESTIGATION PIT
>> CONVICTED OF THE CRIMES IN
THE INVESTIGATION, MR. MENOTTI
WOULD FACE A SENTENCE OF 333
YEARS IN FEDERAL PRISON.
>> Laura: HE WAS PRACTICALLY
COHOSTING SHOWS ON CNN, WASN'T
HE?
BUT HERE WE ARE, AND DEMOCRATS
FACING ANOTHER BRILLIANT LEGAL
MIND WITH IMPECCABLE
CREDENTIALS.
THEY WENT BACK TO THE PROP
CLOSET ONCE AGAIN.
>> CHICKEN BARR SHOULD HAVE
SHOWN UP TODAY AND ANSWERED
QUESTIONS.
HE WAS AFRAID OF BARRY BURKE,
AFRAID -- AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO WAS PICKED FOR HIS LEGAL
ACUMEN, AND HE WOULD NOT BE
FEARFUL OF ANY OTHER ATTORNEYS
QUESTIONING HIM FOR 30 MINUTES.
>> Laura: DOES HE SLEEP WITH
THAT CHICKEN?
I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS PRONOUNCED
"ACUMEN," I GUESS I AM WRONG.
THE REAL CHICKENS ARE THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE TOO AFRAID TO
ADMIT THAT THEY GOT IT ALL WRONG
AND RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
THEY ARE TOO AFRAID TO ACTUALLY
ADVANCE AN AGENDA TO DEFEND WHAT
OTHER POLICIES THEY WANT TO
FORWARD NOW, IN THE MIDST OF A
ROARING TRUMP ECONOMY.
THAT IS HARD STUFF.
SO THEY REVERT TO THEIR SAME OLD
TACTICS, WHICH WE HAVE EXPOSED,
BY THE WAY, AND DOCUMENTED FOR
ALL OF YOU.
WITH NO GLEE, BUT WE HAVE HAD TO
DOCUMENT BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT.
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, WE DID THAT
ON THE SHOW.
AND JUST LIKE WITH KAVANAUGH,
THEY ARE NOW CALLING FOR SOMEONE
ELSE'S HEAD ON A PLATTER.
>> I THINK ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR OUGHT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT HE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
RESIGN PAID >> YOU'LL BURN
THROUGH ANY CREDIBILITY IN THAT
ROLE, AND I THINK HE SHOULD
RESIGN.
>> I THINK HE SHOULD RESIGN, AND
HE HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
ONE, HE IS NOT ABLE TO PERFORM
HIS DUTIES.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, BY THE
WAY, THAT BOTH KAVANAUGH AND
BARR ARE BUSH REPUBLICANS.
SO WHEN YOU THINK IT IS ALL
ABOUT TRUMP, ANYONE WHO IS
CONNECTED TO THIS ADMINISTRATIO
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO AFTER YOU
IF YOU HAVE A R AFTER YOUR NAME.
MY PREDICTION, THE MORE BARR
LEARNS ABOUT WHO AND WHAT WERE
BEHIND THE 2016 EFFORTS TO SMEAR
TRUMP, THE NASTIER AND MORE
DESPERATE THE DEMOCRATS ATTACKS
ON BARR WILL BECOME.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE TO
SPECIFICS, I TALKED TO
HOROWITZ A FEW WEEKS AGO ABOUT
IT, AND IT IS FOCUSED ON THE
FISA, THE BASIS FOR THE FISA,
AND THE HANDLING OF THE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
BY NECESSITY, IT LOOKS BACK A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER THAN THAT.
>> Laura: THERE MUST BE A LOT
OF OBAMA DEMOCRATS IN AND OUT OF
THE DEEP STATE WHO ARE SWEATING
NOW.
THEY NEED BARR'S REPUTATION TO
BE TARNISHED.
THAT WAY, WHATEVER BARR
ULTIMATELY CONCLUDES ABOUT THE
OBAMA DOJ CAN BE WRITTEN OFF AS
PRO-TRUMP PROPAGANDA.
THEY HAVE TO DO THAT TO PUT THIS
OUT.
IF HILLARY AND COMPANY HAD MAYBE
SPENT MORE TIME TRYING TO
OUT-DEBATE TRUMP ON THE BIG
ISSUES OF THE DAY RATHER THAN
FUNDING PHONY DOSSIERS, PAYING
ALL OF THAT MONEY TO FUSION GPS,
MAYBE SHE WOULD HAVE FARED
BETTER THE LAST ELECTION, I
DON'T KNOW.
I DO DEMOCRATS TODAY FOCUSED
MORE ON IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
EVERYDAY AMERICANS INSTEAD OF
ACTING OUT THEIR SILLY SCHEMES
IN A "KILL BILL" EQUAL, MAYBE
THEY WOULD HAVE MORE TO SHOW FOR
THEIR FIRST 100 DAYS OF HOUSE
RULE BEEN RIDICULOUS SUBPOENAS
AND CHARACTER ASSASSINATIONS.